we are imperfect but compared to any
other society I'm aware of we have a
stronger system of freedom a greater
capacity for people to rise and a
greater awareness that anybody can come
from anywhere and become an American
[Music]
hey hey and welcome to the sunday
special I'm excited to welcome to the
set former Speaker of the House Newt
Gingrich former 2012 presidential
candidate Newt Gingrich author of the
brand new novel collusion as well as
host of newts world podcast we'll get to
all of the questions for him in just one
second first it's spring the time of
year when seeds grow into flowers and
you grow up financially at least your
family needs protection if something
happens to you that means you need life
insurance thankfully policy genius makes
it easy to get that financial security
without the growing pains policy genius
is the easy way to buy life insurance
online in just two minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers and
find your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape no
Commission's no hidden fees just
financial protection and peace of mind
no strings attached and policy genius
doesn't just simplify life insurance
they also make it easy to compare and
buy home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance all the insurance
you could ever want so next time you
stop to smell the roses pull out your
phone head over to policy genius calm
that's policy genius
spring is here kick it off by nipping
life insurance in the bud be an adult
make sure that you take care of this
problem before you plotz make sure that
if you should plotz you're not buried in
a pauper's grave and your family is
taken care of this is why you should
have life insurance also get all your
other types of insurance over at policy
genius com that is policy genius calm
the easiest way to buy life insurance a
speaker Gingrich thanks so much for
coming to the show really appreciate it
I'm delighted to be with you you've had
a remarkable run and are having a huge
impact well thank you that means a lot
to me so let's start with where do you
think we are politically obviously where
everybody's looking forward to 2020 so I
might ask for a little bit of rank
political analysis here looking forward
to 2020 where do you think that
President Trump stands in terms of
reelection odds at this point well I
think if the economy continues that hid
the odds are better than even he'll win
I think his ability as a campaigner is
something that the left keeps forgetting
I think that the Minister guys had 90 or
92 percent negative coverage for three
straight years and is still standing and
a normal politician would have crumbled
by now and you know going to the New
York Times promised to be a liberal and
whatever they had to to try to get there
not to not beat him up so I think Trump
probably can win I think he is not quite
as disciplined as he ought to be I think
if they feel a little more
one I would think he could win a
crushing victory but everyone said well
just as he starts to build momentum he
decides to tweet something or do
something sort of undercut his own
momentum and I think the Democrats my
reading which and it's different than I
would have thought if we'd done the show
two months ago I think Biden is the
probable nominee just by name ID and
momentum although Hillary was 30 points
ahead of Obama just before the Iowa
caucus in 2008 but if if Biden doesn't
get it I think there's now a wide-open
field because part of what's happening
is you have so many candidates that no
one of them is able to grow very much
and so you have the sort of collection
of I'm not sure pygmies a politically
correct term very very small people and
no ability to climb the ladder at this
point you know Sanders who I think is
decaying the more we get to know about
him know always see his honeymoon
pictures in Moscow and his love fest
with Cuba with the more begin to rise
this capitalism is a nut cake and I
think that the when you drop below those
to almost anybody could emerge in a way
that we can't anticipate do you see
Biden collapsing at all I mean I I agree
with you that right now he's I mean the
polls say he's the most formidable
candidate he's got a hundred percent nay
recognition he seems unthreatening
generally to a huge bulk of the American
public
do you see circumstances under which he
could crumble I mean he was a bad
presidential candidate a couple of other
times but now he's got the VP hallmark
on his on his resume well it's a little
bit you talk it and one of the things I
saw a poster of yours you talked about
the facts and Biden represents the the
feeling wing of America so the facts
don't matter
a little bit like a OC man she
represents the hysterically filling wing
of America and and that among their
people facts don't matter so the fact
and I people forget the first time Biden
collapsed he ran and he had this
wonderful emotional speech about his
childhood growing up in a small town it
turned out it was Neil Kennex speech as
a labor leader
wails now a guy who's from Scranton
representing Delaware describing himself
in terms of a Welsh village who's so
this is back when the news media still
had some sense of covering facts I mean
the news media destroyed him they just
said this is crazy but one of the
failures of my career I'm watching the
Palin Biden debate which is available
online people can check the transcript
and Biden says at one point if you
really won't understand the middle class
I want you to come to Katie's restaurant
on Saturday morning where I go all the
time well in the back of my head that
didn't ring right so I called a friend
in Wilmington and said when did Katie's
clothes
well Katie's closed 13 years before he
said that so I called the McCain
campaign and this tells you a lot about
why Republicans lose and why Trump's
different than normal Republicans I call
him McCain campaign I said put her in an
airplane
tonight fly into Willington with the
national press corps go looking for
Katie's and he'll tell you this guy's a
doofus and that's the danger that he
would have as president as a man so
shallow and so lacking in seriousness
you know Bob gates the Secretary of
Defense for both Obama and Bush wrote in
his memoir that for four decades Biden
has been consistently wrong on every
major national studious you know I mean
Gates is sort of a bureaucrat he's not
not an ideologue but that should sober
people do you really want a guy as
president who's been wrong for four
decades on every major national security
issue now when you talk about you know
his sort of feelings appeal it's pretty
obvious that that basically he's running
a 1920 warren g harding back to normalcy
campaign that effectively what he's what
he's saying is Donald Trump forget about
the policy Donald Trump is too crazy
he's too out there he's too volatile I'm
the solid guy you remember from the from
the Obama administration and you
remember things weren't so bad then
things are things are much worse now in
terms of sort of the American political
sphere I don't think that rings true but
it seems to be effective in a lot of
polls particularly suburban women if
you're president Trump how do you
counter that well I mean first of all
this is one of the great challenges
Trump has because suburban women react
negatively to Trump style man the very
toughness and aggressiveness and
risk-taking which makes Trump so
with blue-collar workers jars suburban
women and that he's got to think through
to what degree he there are two ways to
become more acceptable one is to change
which I think's unlikely the other is to
draw an issue contrast so compelling
that in the end they decide for example
that as mothers they don't want their
children growing up in that kind of
world and so I think you know Trump
probably has to go to the second model
because which is Nixon in seventy two
rather than Reagan and eighty four but
Nixon won the largest popular vote in
American hit modern American history I
mean bigger than FDR being able to get a
bigger popular vote margin because in
the end people said yeah I can't be from
McGovern I think the challenge that that
that Biden has and the reason that I
think it's a difficulty I think there
are there are two simple language sets
there are winners and there are whiners
Biden represents the whining wing of
American politics right now Trump
represents the winning wing so if you if
you like if you're conservative and you
like conservative judges Trump is the
biggest winner in your lifetime if you
like going to work and think it's nice
to have a job Trump is the biggest
winner in modern times I mean if you're
african-american and think the
unemployment rate matters or I think
it's great the wages are going up Trump
is a big winner so I think you know but
that rate leads to a real gap
psychologically the second is I think
the gap between fact and emotion which
is why I found that the the slogan you
use so far so fascinating
the reason our arguments don't work on
the left is the left gets up in the
morning and says but I feel this way and
you try to give them factually of media
to understand in fact there's a there's
an interview that AOC had where the
reporter demolished faction and she
finally stopping by said look I'm
morally correct so the fact that all
those facts are wrong is irrelevant
because it's because you're in two
different psychological arenas and
that's part of our challenge and a lot
of the younger voters who have been in
left-wing colleges and left-wing high
schools have been trained to think only
facts you only emotionally and have been
trained to believe that facts don't
aren't really relevant so let's talk a
little bit about president Trump's
policy because you've written now a
couple of books or your the process of
writing one about China and one about
and you've written this one collusion
which has to deal with with Mara
and foreign policy with regard to Russia
let's talk about president Trump's
foreign policy because that's obviously
coming to a head right now particularly
hard to China one of the great dangers
to his reelect effort is the possibility
of an economic downturn a lot of folks
are concerned that his posturing or that
his position with regard to China
insofar as trade is concerned could
theoretically lead to an economic
downturn where do you stand on president
Trump's trade policies with regard to
China and how much of a threat should we
consider China at this point well I have
a book on October on China and and I
think another didn't spent several years
now researching and I've been looking at
China since 1960 or 1959
I think the China is the most formidable
competitor we've ever seen vastly more
difficult than the Soviet Union I think
that their stock and trade is to cheat
and to be deceptive I think that it's
good to finally have a president who's
figured out that we ought to take him on
I always tell people think about this
you never pick a fight with your biggest
customer we're their biggest customer
they're not our biggest customer we're
not going to get into a recession
because of a fight with China they may
get into a depression because if we cut
you know if people suddenly say as has
happened the last few days where you you
have Google saying they're not going to
have any Android updates available for
Huawei well I mean if we start going
into that kind of that level of
toughness the Chinese are going to face
huge economic problems and as Trump has
said publicly you know we can buy from
Vietnam from the Philippines from
Thailand from India I mean from Nigeria
we have lots of sources for things the
Chinese have only one gigantic customer
to us if they lose that customer through
the transition cost for them will be
enormous
I mean is there the possibility and just
to argue the counter
isn't it possible that China says okay
we're willing to take some temporary
pain just to get Trump out of office
meaning we'll sell American bonds on the
open market we'll take the hit will will
raise our own tariffs on their products
there's a surplus of cash on the planet
I mean that's one of the problems that
Chinese have sell the American bonds we
can find 65 African billionaires who
want to buy them I mean there's no
evidence right now that bonds are going
to go up and I don't think the Chinese
can sell enough furthermore they
disabled
their own banking system I mean the
Chinese I really do think that 30 years
from now this might not be true
particularly if we were to just remain
stupid and slow but if we are prepared
to take them headed for example we just
get him to cut off intellectual property
theft which the Obama director of
national security and national
intelligence said was four hundred and
sixty billion dollars a year that means
they steal more annually than our total
sale to China now we just wrote and then
by the way this is not you know six high
school kids hacking in Shanghai this is
the people Liberation Army units that
are methodical have thousands of people
who get up every morning to hack into
the United States and I think closing
those things down will change the whole
trajectory of the Chinese system so as a
historian now I've often wondered you
know now I look back and I say was it
actually a good idea for Nixon to open
China in the first place given how
antagonistic they've been given the fact
that they were a lot weaker in 1972 than
they are right now given the fact that
us taking a very strong stance with
regard to the Soviet Union on economics
led to the collapse of that system if
you could go back in time do you think
it's a good idea or a bad idea to open
China I actually think it was a
brilliant idea because first of all the
Chinese that fought a skirmish with
Soviets and the Soviets were building up
their military forces in Siberia and
Nixon and the Kissinger had came up with
a model that they were in effect
increasing the relationship with China
to balance off the Soviet Union and at
the time I think that was right
I think where began to change look I was
one of the people who was wrong I mean I
I thought in 1992 when dong-chil
Penguins south and gave what's called
the southern tour which is where he said
we have to have open markets and I don't
care whether a cat is a black cat or a
white cat I care if it catches mice and
I've actually been an in a city where
they actually have a two giant black and
white cats at the bridge like 20 feet
tall but I thought oh yes as most of us
did oh yeah that's the first step
towards opening up the country that's
not true dunk shopping was a Leninist
what he was saying was if the
dictatorship is going to survive we have
to have prosperity
so they actually had some of the people
would have thought was impossible they
have an authoritarian political system
with 90 million members in the Congress
party and they have an open more
relatively open market again it's
government controlled and I wouldn't
exaggerate how open it is but it's but
it's very productive and it is taking
its raised probably 350 million people
in the middle class status
it's an enormous achievement but it's an
achievement financing a dictatorship and
I think sometime in the 90s we probably
should have shifted and realized that
the world that did he once the Soviets
collapsed we should have looked much
more critically at our relationship with
China and once Tiananmen occurred and it
was obvious that done shopping himself
ordered the tanks to go in and crush the
students this should've been a signal to
us maybe our our understanding of
openness and Chinese a little bit wrong
what do you think America's end goal
should be in China is it to contain them
is it to eventually create the
possibility of regime change well I
think our goal should be to contain the
Chinese and minimize their worldwide
influence until they are able to
transition to a free society I mean if
if if China were as free as India or as
free as Great Britain I don't think we'd
be particularly threatened but you
you'll be of a billion four hundred
million people so let's be fair they're
gonna be important they're gonna be big
they're gonna be much bigger than Russia
and that's just I mean if you vote right
if you believe humans matter a billion
400 million people ought to be pretty
big but they have to become not just
less communist they have to become less
Chinese I mean the Chinese system has at
least 3,000 years of authoritarianism it
has a very closed society in many ways
it has a very deep belief going back
thousands of years that it is the
central kingdom and that therefore
everybody else should be paying tribute
to them so you both want to get them to
peel away from a communist centralized
Leninist dictatorship and you want to
get them to decide that they're part of
the human race they're not just a
uniquely Chinese hegemon that the rest
of the UN way should pay tribute to
those are huge changes I may take a long
time and
you have to have a strategy that says
we're going to contain you till that
happens we don't have that strategy
today we're in grave danger of losing to
them just by the sheer momentum of their
technology and their economy so you have
a new book collusion which is all about
the foreign influence of Russia where do
you see Russia in the world in 2012 Mitt
Romney famously declared that they were
the the chief geopolitical threat to the
United States you said that the China's
significantly more dangerous than Russia
yeah what do you think Russia that sort
of ranks here and how should the United
States be treating them I mean I think
first of all Romney was not totally
wrong I think China is a bigger
long-term challenge but you have a
country with about 5,000 nuclear weapons
whose leader was a trained KGB
professional who spent a large part of
his career trying to keep the East
Germans in a slave state who I said we
open our book with it with a quote from
Putin that the Cold War never ended and
we closed our book with seven pages
single lines of all the people we've
been able to find so far that Putin is
killed who you're through seven-page
been to realize I mean I talked to some
of the other day who knows garry
kasparov the great chess player who said
that cad there were six pro freedom
dignitaries of which Kasparov is the
only one still alive and so yeah the
Russians are very dangerous the Russians
have a long history of penetrating the
United States we had one of the top
people Robert Hansen at the FBI who was
actually charged at one point with
finding Russian spies was a Russian spy
for 25 years we had Ames in the CIA who
was a spy for at least 15 years Alger
Hiss in world war ii the number three
guy in the State Department was such an
effective agent for the Soviets that a
Yalta he met secretly with Stalin at
3:00 in the morning and was given the
highest civilian award you can get the
Soviet Union because he'd done such a
great job representing the Soviet Union
inside the US government so we know that
that collusion is real we also know that
the Russians have this weird fascination
with poison it was just last year they
tried to poison a defector in in Britain
and they they liked for you to know that
they're doing it so they tend to use
poised
you can track back to the Russians and
say nobody else on the planet makes this
and I think they do that because Putin
wants to say to potential defectors if
you defect we're going to kill you so I
understand this could happen to you this
could be your faith so we took that
concept of poison
we took the fact that they like to
penetrate our society we looked at ante
foe which is a left-wing fascist
organization and said what you know
could could you have an alliance between
the extreme wing of antifa and the
Russians and an effort to actually
poison the entire US Senate and that's
the novel really starts to build and
then we decided to make it very modern
by having our central figure Brett
Garrett is a Navy SEAL who was hurt
severely in a helicopter crash during an
operation in Nigeria and was treated for
pain with opioids and became an opioid
addict and so we have a central figure
who is wrestling with his own addiction
while he's serving the country and in my
podcast you mentioned the window at
mitts world we now do podcasts we did
one podcast with a 30 year CIA veteran
on how do you get people out of Moscow
and then the Russians are trying to kill
them and then we did a podcast a week
later with two army combat doctors who
are specifically assigned to develop non
addictive painkillers and what they're
doing and how they're doing it and
somehow it was fascinating when they
they have an ability now to let's say
your hands been burned they have an
ability to to have an injection right
here it simply cuts the nerves
temporarily from your hands so you don't
actually feel it and it doesn't a dict
you and it doesn't affect the rest to
your body and they said they put out in
combat and I can get you to stay awake
so you can get yourself on the
helicopter
I just saved an enormous amount of
effort versus putting you to sleep for
the pain and now four other people have
to get you on the helicopter and stuff
like that it was a fascinating interview
so the book is great I had a chance to
read it over the weekend it's really
enjoyable and really informative as well
when people see the title collusion
obviously the first thing they think of
is the mullah report so have you had a
chance to write by the way that was it
was pure luck that they came out the
same
although although the concept grew out
of all this talk about could you have
collusion and but that was you know
books take a while right he started this
a year and a half ago well worked out
well in terms of marketing that's right
so given the fact that collusion is sort
of the tip of everybody some
particularly in the media I know if
you've had a chance to read or digest
the the Muller report what was your take
on on the Muller report the kind of
final result the president obviously has
declared that it was a witch-hunt from
the very beginning do you believe that
it was a witch-hunt from the very
beginning do you believe that it sort of
went wrong in the middle or do you
believe that the president was guilty in
any way of anything approaching
obstruction of justice which seems like
the more meaty part of the report well I
have a larger historic view of the Mulla
report I believe that there was a
serious effort at a coup d'etat by the
deep state that included certainly the
Attorney General the head of the FBI a
series of Lies told to federal judges a
extraordinary effort to or
destroy the nominee of a major party and
at the same time a remarkable effort
which people still haven't dug into to
protect the Democratic nominee I mean
people want to talk about obstruction of
justice and I said I'm great let's talk
about 33,000 emails that are deleted
let's talk about Telus cell phones that
are beating up with a hammer let's talk
about bleach fit for your computer
hardware with that if Trump had done
that would you thought that was
obstruction I mean if you look at it the
the the one-sidedness of our standard
here
that if Trump has a conversation in the
Oval Office about a totally legitimate
constitutional right which anybody in
the executive branch could be fired and
that that's the prep part of the
president's constitutional authority as
the chief executive suddenly we're
worried about whether or not he's
obstructing justice if Hillary Clinton
goes through everything I just said to
you it's a non-event and that's part of
the corruption of the system these guys
thought that Hillary is going to win and
they thought they could get away with
anything
if she'd won I I think it's very
sobering how corrupt the system would
have gotten under her in one of the
things that was obviously very telling
was the fact that James Comey
ineffectively exonerating her wrote
intent into a law that does not have a
component of intent and then when they
talk about obstruction of justice
suddenly they are reading intent out of
the law requires intent to obstruct
justice that's one of the things that
struck me about the malla report on the
other hand you look at the president's
behavior and the president effectively
allegedly telling Don began to lie to
the press the president creating
statements on behalf of Donald from jr.
this sort of stuff is not criminal but
it is but it is bad I think that was not
a great report for the president no
friend of mine sent me this this
internet story but a guy who had
dragoons in his basement and he said
this really nice guy showed up in a
really nice suit and he went down and
when he left there was still raccoons
and this other guy showed up but he
really had a degree from Harvard and
when he went down there was still
records and then there's really
rough-and-tumble guy who's a little bit
obnoxious showed up and there are no
more raccoons which one would you hire
but on the left the hatred of Trump is
so deep that people at the New York
Times and Washington Post and CNN get up
in the morning and they go I know Trump
did something terrible I wonder what it
is
and then they go looking for something
terrible which has to be something
terrible because that's they have a
daily terrible requirement it's like a
feeding schedule Donald Trump have been
and I did nobody gives you any slack but
so but I'm gonna describe what slack
will look like to historians Donald
Trump is a billionaire construction real
estate finance guy who was clever enough
to have a successful reality show for 14
years which for four years was the
number one TV show who then had the most
successful tie in America who runs I
think 18 golf courses and a whole bunch
of other buildings and hotels who is
shameless self propagandizing there's a
if you go on on the YouTube there are is
there a series of Pizza ads
I think from the early 90s you know
which this kid shows up and knocks the
door for Domino's and says and Trump
answers and the kid says Oh mr. Trump
here are your three pizzas for $15 news
wait a second kid I gotta negotiate
tell you what I'll give you five dollars
a piece okay looking totally mystified
hands in the pizzas and they close in on
Trump's face and he goes
Donald you still got it his willingness
to make fun of himself while Domino's
paid for ads to make him more famous we
know it lifts itself take that
personality no government experience no
sophisticated sense of what you can and
can't do and he claws his way to the
presidency beating 15 other Republicans
the news media and Hillary Clinton and
he turns around and he's pissed off and
he acts like the CEO he is which is not
appropriate for the president's aides so
if you want to say that he have to go
through a learning curve I think that's
totally fair you want to say was it
malicious or designed to in some way
undermine the Constitution I think
that's an absurdity so let's talk about
that for a second cuz a lot of Democrats
are of course pushing toward impeachment
not Nancy Pelosi who knows better but a
lot of the other Democrats at this point
are pushing impeachment obviously you
were involved in an impeachment effort
against President Clinton I wonder if
you could distinguish the two like what
were the grounds that you think were
appropriate to impeach President Clinton
as opposed to the attempts to impeach
President Trump well I always tell
people if you go back and you look at
ken starr's report which I went back and
pulled it up because I had that exact
that's true I think there was a long
time ago yeah well Ken Starr issues a
report which has 11 counts in which he
says he is guilty
okay five of them are obstruction
discount guilty discount guilty if more
and issued a report that said Donald
Trump is guilty on 11 counts there would
be an impeachment effort there might
they would probably fail because the
Republican Senate won't impeach just as
the house impeach but the Senate refused
to convict with Clinton which might have
been actually the right constitutional
solution but in Clinton's case remember
he was guilty enough
he lost the license to practice law in
Arkansas he had to pay a fine he was
clearly guilty in Trump's case Moeller
comes back and says there's nothing
there that you could take him to court
on there's a pretty big gap here so when
you look at that impeachment effort and
you look back historically a lot of
Republicans now who look at it and say
well we never should have done that do
you have any Gretz about the impeachment
effort do you think it was the right
move I think I was too aggressive and I
think that I think Pelosi is both Pelosi
and Tip O'Neill have handled impeachment
better than I did because he they
deliberately took a half step back and
made the Judiciary Chairman more
important and I'd been such a large
figure at that time the Republican Party
was very hard to do but I think I would
give myself bad marks I don't know how
you get a report it says the president I
say so remember in Clinton's case
they're felonies
I mean it always strikes me the
feminists who worry about this you know
Clinton was conveniently in a sexual
harassment lawsuit alleging this goes
back to the whole current you know issue
about it harassment in workplaces so
he's being sued by an Arkansas state
employee because as governor he
attempted to intimidate her now you
would think every feminist in the
country would have been enraged instead
they were so defensive of liberalism
that they were enraged that we would
take serious the degree to which Clinton
was breaking the law so when he commits
perjury again lying under oath not just
lying to the country which he did at a
TV speech but lying under oath that is a
felony and the reason it's a felony is
if people can get away with perjury the
entire structure of the rule of law
collapses and so we're faced with I mean
if he came back to me again today with
the same facts I'd handled him in a more
subtle way in a more sophisticated way
but I would in fact I said and I think
he star frankly also made a mistake
because his report is too much about sex
and not enough about the law I mean I
think if he had indicated the the risk
to women of allowing the employer to
commit perjury without punting
consequence uh he would've had a much
stronger case well talking about the
role of Congress so obviously you're one
of the most powerful speakers in in the
history of the country and one of the
things that that has struck me
particularly since the the rise of the
Obama era is the extent to which it
seems like Congress has become a
vestigial organ of government that
everything seems to be done by the
executive branch at this point it seems
like Congress can't get anything done or
won't get anything done
it seems like the the initial bargain
the founders were deeply worried about
the ambition of folks and so they said
okay well ambition will check ambition
it seems like to a certain extent they
never first saw the rise of a group of
unambitious legislators whose goal is
going to be to kick as much power as
possible to the executive branch and
that's to avoid culpability are you
worried about the the checks and
balances in the system as we see in my
opinion an ever more powerful executive
branch and an ever less powerful
legislative one well I'm worried about a
very long range trend which probably
goes back to the 30s which is to give
power to the
bureaucracy not not to the president but
to the bureaucracy so you have you have
bureaucrats now making decisions that I
think the founding fathers would have
said should have been the legislative
branch decisions you know I think
actually the appointment of the
conservative judges is probably going to
shrink the relative ability bureaucracy
to do that I think that in fact the
Congress is very powerful but it's
powerful in ways that don't fit the
hunger of the modern news media I mean
if you were to say to Trump today how
powerful has the Democrats and
Congressman that's screwing up your
border policy you'd say well pretty darn
powerful if you look at how hard they're
working to create a space force and the
degree to which they have to
nickel-and-dime their way through the
House and Senate I think they tell you
this there's an immense amount of
institutional power that that is there
that's real that you can't get away from
now I think on small things
I mean Lamar Alexander and fred Upton
last year passed a 21st century cures
bill those bipartisan there are lot of
small ways that Congress works pretty
well but I my view is that we're in the
middle of a cultural Civil War and when
you're in that kind of a death struggle
it's very hard to get things to work
because each side feels so passionately
and so deeply about its version of the
culture so I want to ask you given the
fact that we are in the middle of this
calls for war the big issue that nobody
likes to talk about Paul Ryan likes to
talk about it but they never could get
anything done on it it's obviously the
the entitlements the welfare state the
fact that 66 percent of our budget 2/3
is composed of Social Security Medicare
Medicaid the fact that nobody seems to
want to do anything about it and the
fact that Republicans are blowing out
the spending themselves you know a lot
of folks like to talk about the 1990s
and Bill Clinton being more fiscally
responsible the fact is that you're
running Congress at that time and that
had something to do with it what what do
you think has changed inside the
Republican Party do you think that the
future of the Republican Party is
effectively a big spending
european-style right party well I mean
first of all but take some pride in
being the only Speaker of the House in
your lifetime who balanced the budget
for for eight years so it is
theoretically doable because we did it
I think that that actually there there
are steps that are beginning to be taken
that are encouraging I think if I could
divide what you describe as the welfare
state into three very different
components I mean one is the work ethic
getting people with shifting from focus
on disabilities to capabilities we look
look what wounded warriors to do and
then look at 31 year-old truck drivers
of the bad back could have said they
can't be retrained and the whole model
of disability has to be rethought and
focused on capabilities that would
change the trajectory of cost very
dramatically I think second Social
Security the answer in part is to
dramatically increase private savings
and to recognize that a system designed
when people live to be 55 has to be
rethought when people are gonna live to
be 90 and in fact you see at a practical
level it's being rethought more and more
people 65 70 75 were working both
because they want the money but also
because three generations ago you worked
physically and if you were in a steel
mill or you were out plying on a mule
you were physically broken by the time
you were 55 or 60 nowadays you tend to
work with your brain it turns out your
brain doesn't age very fast and so
people want to stay active they actually
live longer if they don't go to fewer
retirement and so you're gonna see more
and more people I think beginning to
relieve the pressure in that sense the
other part of that is a cultural problem
that across the board and that is we
went in the 50s from a country that said
you really should save up and then do
something to countries that said oh no
no you ought to charge it on your credit
card and pay it off later whether that's
a student loan program or anything else
and so shifting back towards a more
savings or in a society was just partly
the tax code making it very profitable
and desirable to save the the other zone
is health care and health care is very
different I've spent much of my life
since 1974 in health care I founded the
Center for Health Transformation wrote a
book called saving lives and saving
money the key the key to the health
system and then this is the whole key to
the health insurance problem is to
dramatically reduced
cost we spend I think 40% more on health
care than we should we would get we get
a better system with better results
migrating and evolving faster if an and
to their credit secretary a czar that
Health and Human Services and the
president and vice president have really
begun to move the system towards more
knowledge where you or I mean they think
for example they think if you go in for
a procedure you ought to know what it's
going to cost
and of course up till now basically the
doctor in the hospital said well we
don't really know what the complications
are it said it's a sin oh no you have to
take a sophisticated best judgment tell
the patient and live with it well that's
going to change people are going to
start shopping a lot better I mean today
it's almost impossible if you have three
hospitals you could go to in your
neighborhood it's impossible to know
which one will cost you more and so
people often end up being very surprised
that I had a friend who I thought
everything was covered until they found
out that the anesthesiologist was out of
the system and so they had to pay an
extra thousand dollars they hadn't
counted on you know because the bill
showed up six weeks later and that's the
sort of so there are a lot of things
like that I think what they're doing on
on this whole issue of rebates which is
if you think about it's an absurdity the
the big pharmacy benefit managers really
have as their big sales pitch but I can
give you a huge rebate now why can I
give you a huge rebate because the enemy
of the pharmacy it's pharmaceutical
company just charge me a lot extra to
create the space for me to give you a
large rebate so guess what the long-term
pressure is I want them to charge me
more so I can give you an even bigger
rebate well I'm keeping the same number
of dollars and there has always been a
20-year cycle of prices going up that
are absurd I mean isn't it also true the
debt that cycle of prices rising across
the board has a lot to do with the
increase in government subsidies that's
been driving the Medicare system up and
up and up
well actually the Part B came in about
40% cheaper than anybody expected
because it is competition and I think
that you're gonna see more and more
things like that part of what we need to
do is figure out if you're gonna have a
high deductible how do we create a tax
basis for you to have enough money saved
I mean it doesn't do us any good to
create a $7,000 deductible if you can't
afford it because what it then means is
that you're gonna end up back in debt
the hospital is either gonna eat the
debt or sue you it's a really bad way to
think about health care so moving
forward and you've talked about health
care and you've talked about Social
Security do you think there's the will
to do any of these things because it
seems like the the political will
is entirely in the other direction
meaning exploding benefits we've we've
gradually achieved a little bit of it
under Trump I think we'll achieve more
remember if you're an Obama Democrat or
if you own any of the current Democratic
candidates and I say to you because the
economy is growing the number of people
on food stamps has dropped by 12 million
you think that's terrible
you know if you're a conservative you
think that's wonderful they're back at
work they're earning a living they don't
need the subsidy but if you're a liberal
you think oh my god this we can't have
the welfare state shrink but that's why
I do great examples when we passed
welfare reform we split the Democrats
50/50 literally 101 to 101 well the 101
who were opposed thought this is the
most horrible thing ever you you're
gonna make people go to work you know
and they don't believe in making people
go to work in fact there's some of them
who believe we ought to give you a check
every month just for being around that's
the kind of thing that you have to look
at where you really see a dramatic
difference in the two parties and you
see a dramatic difference in terms of
what you're trying to accomplish I think
some of that can be done I do think that
if you look for example what Mary Mayhew
did in Maine in the last governorship
they simply they they had done a study
and figured out how many food stamps
were being the main food stamps were
being cashed in Hawaii how many were
being cashed at Disneyland or Disney
World and so forth how many you know how
many were being cashed at their local
racetracks and they began to develop a
pattern that said no you you know if you
draw food stamps in Maine you have to
spend them in Maine because we're not
going to subsidize you going to Disney
World you know if you're if you're in
good enough shape to go Disney World
went into a job and that was a huge
shock to people the idea that you you
know where we are so I think we want to
be the party of work let the other
people be the party of dependency and
then the country is gonna have to choose
so speaking of that choice I mean you've
talked about that the culture war
obviously you see especially among young
people real ignorance as to what
socialism is and also a certain love for
countries in which they've never lived
places like Norway or Denmark
this is the new pitch from Democratic
Socialist Venezuela and Soviet Union are
not good representatives of socialism
anymore now
Norway and Denmark that are the best
representatives of socialism how do you
fight back against that argument best
because it seems like the argument being
made is shara prosperous wonderful
countries with broad social safety nets
and deep social safety nets what's so
wrong with that here in the United
States well first of all you bring in
Swedes and Danes and Norwegians who will
tell them they're not socialist
countries their welfare state countries
big difference they actually have very
very robust capitalism began in the case
of Norway for example there this huge
offshore natural gas find which is
created and they've shown huge
discipline and they have a trillion
dollars sitting in the bank that they
don't spend now imagine an American
politician who was running for
reelection with a trillion dollars
sitting in the bank and so they're very
tough-minded and they and they think
yeah the things will pay for through the
government but that's the welfare state
side but in order to have a really
dynamic economy we want you know we want
very bold capitalism and all those
countries are much more capitalist than
than socialist boom again
Unidas confusion this is why I think the
distinction between facts and emotion is
so important that you have you have over
here liberals who believe in emoting
these are the people who love Fidel
these are the people who conspired to
not tell the truth about Stalin killing
people during the Great Famine when he
was wiping out the kulaks these are the
people who really think that well as one
Democrat representing said the other day
the reason Venezuela is a mess as the US
you know because it's always as Jean
Kirkpatrick once said it's always blame
America first some of those people
you'll never get because they're crazy
and then you have to I mean I'm pretty
cheerful about saying that when you ask
you about certain people ago yeah I mean
AOC is just crazy since she said she has
no connectivity with reality as a great
con job as she wanted she won a very
small turnout election in a district
where nobody cared with and I still
survived next time I think it's a little
less likely because of her opposition to
the Amazon jobs coming into New York
City and the fact that people suddenly
figured out wait a second that was their
potential job
so but I think that we this every two
generations you have this fight in the
thirties you had this fight over the
nature of communism and then again I
think in the late 60s we had this fight
you know the the golden era of Bernie
Sanders going to the Soviet Union for
his honeymoon
was it was a huge question mark George
McGovern ran is the candidate of rampant
socialism and got crushed and for a
generation Democrats thought well that's
not a very good idea do you think we on
the right have made a mistake as far as
how we characterize socialism meaning
it's it's it's a label that we like to
use a lot on the right and maybe we've
over applied it so when it comes to
Barack Obama or Obamacare the chart is
very simple
the reason Obama care was so dangerous
was it was it was designed to move
towards total government control of your
health system now I mean the nice thing
about the current cycle of Democrats
where there's Kamala Harris or it's the
Governor of California Newsom or it's
Bernie Sanders is they're pretty open
about saying yeah I want the government
to control you're helpless
well that is the I mean so many once
said socialism is communism without the
secret police and you just need to
understand that it's altima Lee the
interim step towards it to a
totalitarian control of your life that's
why you know the hold the power of
Hayek's the Road to Serfdom and his own
coming to the conclusion that you could
not have centralized planning with our
dictatorship which I think's barycenter
whether it's a great story Margaret
Thatcher becomes the leader of the
opposition party in 1978 and she's at
their big annual party rally and she
says people ask me what is our platform
and she reaches into this giant purse
she's carrying she pulls out hi X
constitution of Liberty which is a very
fat book and she slams it and says this
is our platform
the idea of any American president
presidential candidate being so
intellectual that they would put a
500-page Hayek book on this and then say
on a TV show that's our platform
it's almost unthinkable so how do we
draw the line when we're when we're
making the argument in favor of
capitalism how do we draw the line with
regard to the welfare state so you say
that a lot of these socialist
socialist leaning countries but have
with capitalist roots Norway Denmark
Sweden and that a lot of the rooted in
capitalism they have a broad social
safety net how do we draw the balance
between an appropriate social safety net
and now we're moving too far and we're
sliding toward a so I think the the
better the better arguments personal do
you want to be a client or a customer do
you want to define for the company what
product you want to buy or do you want
the bureaucrat to define for you what
you're allowed to buy now if you'd like
to give up power and have bureaucrat in
Washington define your life tell you
what you can do what you can't do then
fine just understand because this is
always about freedom
I mean socialism is simply an excuse to
coerce you through bureaucracy so that
some group of people usually college
professors I can feel like they're
really powerful it's their it's their
resentment of the entrepreneurial class
creating wealth and so they want to some
somehow block all these people over here
from creating wealth so they can then
distribute the wealth so they can be in
charge so in 2012 you run for president
and there is this moment where you take
the lead and the lead was really I cite
it as a case in point of something the
media don't understand they think that
President Trump ripping on the media is
what has led to their low approval
ratings and I always point to the fact
that you took the lead in the
presidential race on the national level
based on the fact that you savaged John
Harwood on national television by going
directly at the media uh what is it that
folks do not understand about the nature
of the media ecosystem why do they get
the impression that Trump is the one who
suddenly discovered that the media were
left-wing when as long as I have been
alive and in this business and for me
that's about 20 years for you it's been
longer the media have always been an
opponent of conservatism oh well I mean
first of all you have two great sources
of cultural knowledge the media and
college professors and high school
teachers both are left so both spend all
day every day giving you baloney and
dishonesty and disinformation
fits them and I think you have to start
with that and then they want the right
to define what the issue is and and you
know I've been really working on this
because I'm them very troubled Reagan
and Thatcher and I all three failed to
change the culture of our parties
I mean Reagan was a great communicator
Thatcher was a remarkable communicator
an educator I think I did pretty well in
the contract period and yet none of us
could get conservatives to understand
the the essential characteristics of how
you have to win and the first step of
that is to have the moral courage to
refuse to let the other side define the
issue and and it actually started for me
at that and Chris Wallace gets reminds
me of this occasion because it's seared
into his brain the first real break
point for me I mean I'd seen Reagan do
it I'd done it a little bit but as a
candidate you're in a different
environment and presidential candidate
surprising amount of attention and we
were doing the first Fox debate and at
the very beginning of it Bret Baier says
we're now can have any Mickey Mouse
questions or any Mickey Mouse answers
we're going to stick to big things and I
wrote it down because I thought this
will never so we got the particular
point and I got asked a question that
Chris will will tell you this because
Chris asking I stopped and I said Chris
you know I wrote down with Brett said
and he said no Mickey Mouse questions I
think you just failed that well that
would have been fun but all of a sudden
spontaneously 3,000 people in this
auditorium were applauding and all of me
by the way I got bad enough part of my
demise was Romney's money and dishonesty
part of my demise was the last two
debates they refused to allow audience
participation and I should have blown up
at both Alicia's said that's you don't
have the right to dictate to the
American people but I was in settings
where Romney had intelligently packed
the audience and they probably would
have booed me for taking on the media
which is a real change so what happened
was after the Fed that first debate I'm
going back from Iowa through through
O'Hare and this pilot walks up to me
I've never met he says I loved last
night I am so glad you stuck it to those
people I am so sick of them lecturing us
and I suddenly thought there's something
real happening here now let me give you
a quick parallel 1956 1965 Ronald Reagan
decides to run for governor knows he
doesn't know how to run for office hires
the best firm in California and best
Republican firm and they create a whole
box of issues for him to memorize and as
an actor he can do it very fast and
they're gonna do a series of town hall
meetings where people ask him questions
and he proves he knows enough to be
governor okay because people back then
thought how can an actor beYOU go to the
first town hall meeting first question
what are you gonna do about Berkeley
what about those students not in the box
comes back and he says guys but we need
an answer so no no it's not an issue
second town on me first question other
bucks what are you gonna do about
Berkeley because rocky says guys if they
think it's an issue it's an issue well
the same thing that happened to me I
suddenly realized that the hunger on our
side for somebody to stand up to the
media and say no I'm not gonna let you
do this and it showed up with Trump in
the very first debate which was also Fox
when he got in a brutal nasty and I
think embarrassing fight with megyn
kelly and everybody in the elites I
watched it that night with Kalista
everybody in the leads after the debate
said Trump lost 16 people Trump lost the
online polls average 70% said Trump won
and I thought wait a second if and this
was thousands and thousands of people
and not just conservative publications
if 70% of people think he won out of 16
people and all of the elites are
convinced he lost we're now looking at a
gap about reality that is enormous and
that's where we are today because they
are so caught up in their own culture
and their own social status that they
can't learn so the New York Times I mean
I'd love the other day the New York
Times does page one Donald Trump was in
debt well if you've got
the art of the comeback the opening page
says I owed nine hundred and twenty
three million personally in several
billion corporately and I was in big
trouble the fact that The Times was
suddenly shocked 25 years later like
something he'd written about just tells
you how out of touch they are and how
sick they are so what do you think the
future the media are going to be because
you're right that they're stuck in a
track that they can't seem to be I
appreciate that
no no I mean you generically yeah the
future of the media is a self sorting
mechanism in which the people who make
sense over time
gain a huge advantage and the people who
spend the time in the effort and I
suspect if you're like Sean Hannity for
example the number of hours you spend
studying and getting ready the stuff you
do the team you have around you if
people can say you know I learned things
I didn't know and I thought ideas I
didn't have and I'm really glad I spent
that hour that's the media and
tragically I mean I grew up when when
the news media newspapers were real and
in the New York Times for a hundred
years was an amazing newspaper although
in the 30s they had a reporter who want
to Pulitzer Prize for lying mendacious
lee all that constantly about Stalin to
defend and protect Stalin and in this
50s they had a reporter who got a
Pulitzer for lying about Castro so The
Times has always had a streak of
anti-semitism and a streak of pro
communism but other than that it it's
been a fairly good newspaper but now the
whole culture of the newsroom is
collapsing so we see the the extent to
which the culture war is raging it I
mean to the point where people won't
allow other people to eat in their
restaurants we have bans from certain
government officials on officials
traveling to other states and I wonder
if the are you optimistic about the
future of the country do you think that
we hold things in common anymore or are
the divides now so deep that they're
moving toward the irreconcilable years
ago I was in the greenroom with Charles
Krauthammer and he asked me that
question and I said oh I'm pretty
optimistic I said you know we're still a
long way short of the Civil War he
looked nice to wait the Civil War yeah
so I would say I think this is going to
be a people say to me when is it going
to get better and I say when one side
wins I mean whether the left wins of the
right wins so sooner or later one side
will win
and then the system will calm down for a
while because the side that wins will
have dominance the reason is so brutal
right now is that the relative balance
of power and this is a tribute to Trump
I mean the left has all the instruments
of higher education all the instruments
of K through 12 in public schools all
the instruments the news media all the
instruments of Hollywood and Trump
offsets amo this is one of the great
achievements in American history and
it's really worth a lot more study than
people have given it looking at
President Trump one of my main concerns
in 2016 about President Trump
specifically with regard to this was
that well he satisfies a lot of folks in
terms of him punching the other side
which is well deserved I've described it
as a hammer I say it's very satisfying
when he hits a nail it's not quite as
satisfying when he hits a baby but with
but with that said in the the people who
tend to be most offended are the people
of my generation so people who are
Millennials and younger
he's very unpopular with people who are
older than that seem to get President
Trump on a different gut level do you
think that that conservatism is
penetrating or can penetrate to people
who are younger via the Trump message
because there's no question that he's
great at fighting back he's a great
counter puncher as he himself has said
but does that have the danger carrying
with it of alienating people who are
gonna be the the up-and-coming next
generation well I think Trump in that
sense is more like Thatcher and less
like Reagan and Reagan was very
personable and very careful and Reagan
had said to a friend of mine in 1980
that he couldn't do certain things
because he wore the white hat and it did
so he understood the limits of his
personality and the limits of his appeal
I think Trump's attitude is he's wearing
a hard hat and he doesn't mind being in
a brawl and I think he's going to make
basically two arguments to young people
the first argument is going to be that
the other side represents the end of
your world and there's an enormous risk
which was in a sense the McGovern
Mondale argument and both of those were
crushing defeats the other arguments
going to be whether you like me as a
person your life is better with my
presidency so if you like full
employment if you like rising wages etc
then I represent a better future for you
and
if you would if you would rather have
unemployment but you really feel good
because Uncle Joe tells you how much he
likes you on food stamps or if you'd
rather have full employment by the way
you got this boss is slightly whacked
it's your choice and yeah let me think
about it
this is a guy who's successful show
which is a remarkable achievement people
underestimate how what a great
achievement The Apprentice was this guy
whose most famous line before I ran for
president was you're fired
I mean what kind of guy do you think
he's so you spent your entire career not
just in politics but also studying in
teaching history you've written a bunch
of historical novels you've written a
lot about history and the nonfiction
sphere so when I look at people of my
generation who don't tend to know very
much about history at all what is the
period of history that you would
recommend is the most important for them
to read about given today's
circumstances - I'd recommend deeply
that they read about 1770 to 1790 and
understand what it took to create a free
country and why why we are so different
from Venezuela or China or Russia or
Zimbabwe or Cuba and second I would
recommend they read the period 1850 to
1865 I mean we survived through a brutal
war with an amazing president who
understood what freedom was worth and
who was prepared to fight as long as it
took and I think that we have a very
good friend who teaches at Gettysburg
College who called me at one point and
said the the hatred of Trump on the left
is comparable to the slave-owning
newspapers against Lincoln he said you
can almost see exactly verbatim the same
personality attacks and I think we have
to recognize this is a cultural Civil
War and the best way you can understand
it is to read the two great periods in
which America defined itself well one of
the fascinating things that I've noted
you know I have a history of philosophy
book that's out and one of the things
that I've noted is that the these sort
of conflict right now in the United
States is effectively a conflict about
visions of history that on the one hand
you have one side of the American people
who I think represents the
that says American history was rooted in
eternal fundamentally good principles
and that we have not always lived up to
those principles but the story of
America is the gradual attempt to live
up to those principles sometimes
stumbling and falling but always
generally moving forward and then the
other view of history is the sort of
Charles beard economic view of history
which is these are a bunch of
self-interested actors right people who
are racist sexist bigoted homophobes who
were creating these fake immutable
principles in order to provide
themselves the good feeling as they move
forward with with economics what do you
think is the best way to teach people
about the shadings of American history
because I think one of the great rips on
people on the right is that we are too
sanguine in our view of American history
we have too rosy of view of how American
history is gone
well I'll actually say if there was one
thing I could get every young person to
read this may surprise you it would be a
man for all seasons well either the
movie or the robert ball play of the
play and the reason is it explains
exactly what's so dangerous about the
modern loft because there's a moment
where the son-in-law is explaining to
the Chancellor the Chancellor believes
in the rule of law believes that you
have to be bounded and this young person
is explaining you know that if I had to
go after the devil I would knock down
the wall and he said and then what would
you do I said Neil he said okay so you
knocked down every law until you finally
corner him in Wales and then he turns
what now stands between you and the
devil and I would say to young people
that without getting into an argument
about about the interpretation of
American history they've got to decide
in their lives
do they want to live in a country which
has for 200 and some years said that
your rights come from your Creator and
which has gradually extended that to
every aspect of America or do they want
to live in a country where whatever this
year's passion can be imposed on you by
the state
and they should look at things like in
1984 nor wells great now want as a real
warning when Orwell wrote in 1984 about
Great Britain he did not write it about
Russia and his warning was state
tyrannies are real
and so I would say to them we are
imperfect
and if your yardstick is perfection then
short of the second coming item ah sure
how you get it but compared to any other
society I'm aware of we have a stronger
system of freedom a greater capacity for
people to rise and a greater awareness
that anybody can come from anywhere and
become an American now we one should do
it legally but I always tell people go
down to the National Airport and stand
at the cab stand interview the people
who are waiting in their cabs you'll
find people from Pakistan Ethiopia you
know Guatemala I mean this is the most
diverse society in the history of human
rights more diverse than Roger than in
Rome uh and we are amazingly open to
talent look look at who founded Google
yeah so I think somehow we have to be
prepared to say haven't you know yet
again when you're very young you may not
fully realize this but if you have a
boyfriend or girlfriend the odds are
that they have some flaws if you spend
your entire life looking for perfection
the odds are you gonna be really lonely
except when you look in the mirror and
there by yourself I do have one final
question for you speaker Gingrich
Charlie asked you Lashley two final
questions for I wanna ask you number one
for your generalized history reading
list and I also want to ask you about
whether you think the future of
conservatism is populism and where you
think populism plays into conservatism
given the Trump movement but first if
you want to hear speaker Gingrich his
answer you have to be a daily wire
subscriber to subscribe head on over to
daily wire comm and click subscribe you
can hear the end of our conversation
over there well speaker Gingrich thanks
so much for stopping by everybody should
go pick up a copy of collusion is brand
new book and also give newts world of
listeners for brand new pockets thank
you so much
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis clever edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan Kate's
hair and makeup is by Jess wah alvera
title graphics by Cynthia and hula the
Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
[Music]